Ich bin Sadqouraym.
Ich Teler.
Hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Ich bin heute der Diensthabender Arzt und würde jetzt gerne das Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Sind Sie da mit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich.
Okay. Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Andreas Schultem.
Könnten Sie das langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
Ja. A, N, D, R, E, A, S.
Emil oder?
Ja, Emil.
Okay. Bitte machen Sie weiter.
Mein Name ist Emil.
Emil wie in Nordpol.
Herr Schultem, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 33 Jahre alt.
Okay. Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
1889.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
1,75 Meter.
Wissen Sie, wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ca. 72 Kilo.
Okay. Herr Schultem, was würdet Sie heute sagen? Wie kann ich Ihnen das sagen?
Herr Doktor, ich habe seit ca. vier Tagen starke Kopfschmerzen.
Wo genau sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Die Schmerzen sind linksseitig, meistens hinter dem Kopf.
Hinter?
Hinter.
Die Schmerzen strallen irgendwo hinaus?
Ja, die Schmerzen strallen in den Hals, in die linke Schulter und in den linken Arm.
In den Hals, in die linke Schulter und in den linken Arm?
Ja, ja.
Seit einem Monat habe ich ähnliche Kopfschmerzen, aber ich nehme Ibuprofen.
Und Wermix hilft mir sehr.
Sie haben Ibuprofen dagegen eingenommen, aber hat das gut geholfen?
Seit vier Tagen hat das nicht gut geholfen.
Herr Schultem, sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Langsam begonnen.
Sind sie dauerhaft oder verschwinden Sie seitweise?
Ja, die Agentur ist dauerhaft.
Derzeit ist es schlimmer geworden.
Sie werden im Laufe der Zeit schlimmer?
Ja.
Hab ich richtig verstanden?
Ja, richtig.
Herr Schultem, wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10?
Wobei, 1 Schmerzen und 10 die stärksten Schmerzen bedeuten?
Am mindestens 8.
8, ah.
Es sieht so aus, als ob Sie sehr starke Schmerzen haben.
Möchten Sie Schmerzmittel?
Ja, genau. Es wäre besser.
Haben Sie Allergien gegen bestimmte Medikamente?
Allergien? Ich habe eine Kolonalergien.
Ok, Kolonalergien.
Nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Nein, als Kind.
Nein, nein. Ich meine gegen Ihre Kopfschmerzen.
Sie möchten Schmerzmittel geben?
Ja, ja, habe ich schon gesagt. Ich nehme bei Bedarf...
Nein, nein. Ich meine heute.
Heute? Ja, um 7 Uhr.
Heute haben Sie das eingenommen?
Ja, ja. Am Morgen.
Ich nehme... Ja, ok. Ich gebe andere Medikamente Ihnen.
Jetzt gebe ich der kranken Schwester Bescheid, damit Sie ein anderes Schmerzmittel bekommen.
Ok.
Wie können Sie mir Ihre Schmerzen genau beschreiben, Herr Schalten?
Meine Schmerzen sind sehend und brennend und manchmal dückend.
Aber auf jeden Fall schmerzen Sie die Schmerzen beim Bewegung.
Bei Bewegung. Das ist auch richtig.
Aber Wärmekompressen helfen mir sehr.
Teilweise oder ganz?
Teilweise, ja.
Ok. Gibt es einen bestimmten Auslöser für Ihre Schmerzen, Herr Schalten?
Ja, ein bestimmter Auslöser. Ich habe das leider nicht bemerkt.
Ok.
Haben Sie sich am Kopf verletzt?
Nein. So etwas habe ich nicht.
Ok. Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie dem Erscheinigungen Kraft verlosst haben?
Ja, ein bisschen.
Können Sie mir genau beschreiben?
Ich fühle mich ein bisschen komisch.
Gibt es in meinem linken Arm ein Kribbel?
Was ist mit dem Taubheitsgefühl?
Ja, ein bisschen wenig als normaler.
Ok. Beschreiben Sie Kribbel oder Taubheitsgefühl?
Das konnte ich nicht gut verstehen.
Kribbel.
Wo fühlen Sie sich?
Am linken Arm.
Ganzen Arm oder wo genau im linken Arm?
Besonders vorne.
Ok.
Leiden Sie unter Seherstörungen, Hörstörungen oder Sprachstörungen?
Ja, Sehstörungen oder Hörstörungen habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Aber es fühlt sich ein bisschen übel an.
Übel? Ok.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit etwas Schwieriges gehabt?
Etwas Schweres, Entschuldigung, nicht Schwieriges, etwas Schweres gehabt?
Etwas Schwere? Nein.
Sie haben eben schon gesagt, dass Sie Übelkeit haben.
Haben Sie auch Erbrüchen?
Nein.
Ich habe seit gestern Übelkeit.
Herr Schalten, ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie rechts oder links Händler sind?
Ja, ich bin linker.
Links Händler, ok.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich arbeite beim Rathaus.
Rathaus?
Ich bin Beamter, ein Wohner-Werderamt.
Ein Wohner.
Ein Wohner-Werderamt, ok.
Arbeiten Sie viel am Computer? Ich vermute, das ist so.
Ja, arbeite ich am Computer, an dem Tisch, am ganzen Tag.
Ja, mindestens acht Stunden.
Mindestens acht Stunden?
Ja, mindestens acht Stunden muss ich am Tisch.
Haben Sie Schwindel, Herr Schalten?
Schwindel? Nein, Schwindel habe ich nicht.
Ok.
Herr Schalten, haben Sie Fieber, Stellfluss, Nachschweiß oder kalten Schweiß?
Ja, sowas habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Aber seit vier Tagen habe ich wegen der Schmerzen eine Schlafstörung.
Ich kann nicht so gut schlafen und dann...
Aber die Beschwerden, die ich erwähnte, haben Sie keine?
Haben Sie nicht?
Ok.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen oder Hingefühl oder Atemnot?
Nein, gar nicht.
Habt ihr Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, ganz normal.
Ok. Was ist mit dem Stuhlgang? Haben Sie dabei Probleme?
Ganz normal. Warum fragen Sie?
Ich möchte alle körperlichen Funktionen...
Ich muss Fragen nach körperlichen Funktionen stellen.
Das ist mir etwas komisch. Ich habe Kopfschmerzen und Halsschmerzen.
Beim Stuhlgang würde ich Wasser lassen.
Das verstehe ich. Aber Herr Schalten, wissen Sie, es gibt viele Stammhangen im ganzen Körper.
Zwischen viele verschiedene Teile von Kopf zu Fuß kann ein Stammhang einfach sein.
Ok. In der letzten Zeit habe ich nur ein bisschen.
Ich habe keinen Apathit mehr.
Und außerdem ein bisschen Schlafstörung.
Ok. Und haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ungewollt ab oder zugenommen?
Ich habe nicht mehr mitgemessen.
Herr Schalten, gibt es in Ihrer Vorgeschichte Krankheiten, von denen ich wissen sollte, zum Beispiel chronische Krankheiten wie Bluthochdruck oder erhöhte Blutfeldwerft oder Superkrankheit?
Ja, kann ich so sagen. Seit meinem 14. Lebensjahr habe ich ein Ohrgeräusch.
Ohrgeräusch.
Auch linksseitige.
Ja.
Aber ich nehme keine Behandlung.
Eine Behandlung.
Waren Sie deswegen beim Arzt?
Ja, ca. vor 15 Jahren.
Ok. Noch etwas? Meine ich andere Krankheiten.
Ich denke wegen der Arbeit habe ich generell einen leichten Kopfschmerzen.
Außer diesen Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, außer.
Immer da in der Probe ein oder zwei Mal. Aber nicht so stark.
Nicht so stark wie diese Schmerzen. Ok. Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, mit 15 Jahren bin ich bei Herrn Schalten gestürzt. Deswegen habe ich mir bei mir wieder ein OP durchgeführt.
Was für ein OP erinnern Sie sich daran?
Wegen einer Unterarmdruck. Meine linke Hand war unter der Armdruck.
Links? Ok.
Links.
Unterarmdruck.
Ja, habe ich damals meine linke Hand unter der Armdruck gebrochen.
Ok.
Und dann mit Metall fixiert.
Das habe ich notiert, Herr Schalten.
Herr Schalten, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein? Außer über Profil?
Nein, außer über Profil. Ich nehme kein Medikament.
Wie war die Dosierung von über Profil?
Ohne Ersatz. Ich denke 400.
400. Ok.
Sie haben am Anfang gesagt, dass Sie eine Polenallergie haben. Wie äußert sich Ihre Allergie, Herr Schalten?
Ja, das war als Kind. Ich erinnere mich nicht daran. Mir fällt nicht ein, natürlich.
Aber das wurde mit Eigenbluttherapie behandelt. Ich weiß es nicht. Wissen Sie?
Ja, natürlich. Eigenbluttherapie ist ein Behandlungsverfahren, Herr Schalten.
Dabei wird eigenes Blut dem Patienten entnommen.
Dann wird es aufbereitet. Danach wird es wieder dem Patienten injiziert.
Dadurch kann man behandelt werden.
Ok. Sie sind behandelt.
Herr Schalten, darf ich fragen, ob Sie rauchen oder ob Sie früher geraucht haben?
Ich rauche täglich drei oder vier Zigaretten am Abend.
Seit wann rauchen Sie?
Seit fünf Jahren.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, zwei oder drei Gläserbein am Wochenende.
Herr Schalten, also routinemäßig muss ich Sie fragen, ob Sie mit irgendwelchen Drogen Kontakt haben?
Dann nehmen wir es.
Herr Schalten, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, habe ich schon.
Und ich möchte wissen, ob Sie regelmäßig Sport treiben?
Sport? In der letzten Zeit leider habe ich kein Sport treiben.
Jetzt würde ich Ihnen gerne einige Fragen zu Ihrer Familie stellen.
Sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Ja, mein Vater war vor zwei Jahren an Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Oh, es tut mir leid, dass Sie selbst verschwanden sind.
Danke Ihnen.
Was ist mit Ihrer Mutter?
Meine Mutter hat Bluthochdruck.
Mein Vater hatte auch Herzkrankheit.
Ich denke, das kann sein, dass ich auch eine Herzkrankheit habe.
Mein Vater hatte eine linken Arme Schmerzen.
Ich habe auch.
Ich verstehe Ihre Sorge, Herr Schalten.
Das ist gut nachvollziehbar.
Wir werden das abklären.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorge, aber ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass Sie eine Herzkrankheit haben.
Nach bisherigen Angaben gehe ich nicht davon aus.
Mein lieber Vater sagte mir damals, dass ich eine linken Arme habe.
Wie gesagt, ich verstehe Ihre Sorge, aber diese können andere Dinge verursachen.
Diese Ausstrahlung wird anders verursacht.
Herr Schalten, sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin nicht verheiratet.
Ich lebe mit meinen Freunden.
Sie haben eine faste Beziehung?
Ja, natürlich.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Keine Kinder.
Herr Schalten, ich danke Ihnen für Ihre Offenheit und für Ihre Geduld.
Ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Laut Ihren Beschwerden habe ich den Verdacht auf funktionelle Herdwirbelsäule-Syndrom.
Das kann mit Fehlhaltung, Überbelastung oder Verschleiß auftreten.
Aber das bleibt nur eine Vermutung.
Deshalb müssen wir weitere Untersuchungen durchführen, um das zu bestätigen.
Ich werde Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann nehmen Sie etwas Blut für das Labor ab.
Danach machen wir einen EKG, um eine mögliche Herzursache auszuschließen.
Danach werden wir eine Rundgernaufnahme Ihres Halses veranlassen.
Ich verstehe, aber ich habe niemals etwas Schweres aufgehoben.
Warum habe ich diese Halswirbelsäule-Probleme?
Auch Halswirbelsäule-Syndromen können viele verschiedene Ursachen haben.
Zum Beispiel Entzündung, Fehlkörperhaltung, Verschleiß.
Das kann viele verschiedene Ursachen sein.
Okay, ich verstehe. Und dann, was ist mit mir los? Ist das gefährlich? Muss ich mutter werden?
Nach bisherigen Stunden sollten Sie hier bleiben.
Ich vermute, dass wir Ihre Beschwerden medikamentös und physiotherapie-tisch behandeln.
Ist das möglich?
Das kann sein. Bis jetzt haben wir nur über Ihre Beschwerden gesprochen.
Ich habe sie nicht körperlich untersucht.
Wir haben die weiteren Untersuchungen nicht erledigt. Deswegen kann ich nicht genau sagen.
Okay Herr Doktor, noch eine Frage. Kann es ein Tumor sein?
Ich vermute nicht. Bitte denken Sie nicht zuerst die Schlechte.
Vorher bin ich hier gekommen. Ich habe im Internet etwas recherchiert. Da steht ein Tumor dahinten.
Ich verstehe Ihre Sorgen. Aber Herr Doktor Goggles macht immer die Gehirn oder die Konfus verwendet.
Bitte vertrauen Sie in Ihre Ärzte.
Ich habe nur Ketchup gefragt. Ich habe nicht gegoogelt.
Das ist auch ein neuer Arzt. Ich verstehe.
Wir haben hier viel Zeit.
Herr Doktor, ich habe noch viel Zeit. Aber Frau Oberst, kann ich alles weiter sagen?
Nein, nein, das ist genug.
Was ist Konzil? Was ist Köpelschuntasuk?
Wenn das alles weitergeht, wird es nicht mehr.
In diesem Fall stellen nicht alle Fragen. Einige Fragen.
Zum Beispiel, wenn der Chetinocer fünf Minuten nach dem Gesprächs hat, kann er viele Fragen bekommen.
Aber wahrscheinlich hat er ein oder zwei Minuten und er bekommt nur zwei Fragen.
Ist das gefährlich? Wie können Sie mich behandeln?
Es gibt Tumor, Köpelschuntasuk, Röntgenaufklärung, Behandlungaufklärung, EKBG-Aufklärung. Es gibt viele Reaktionen.
Okay. Ipek Abla, möchtest du einen Anruf machen?
Gerne. Kling-Kling.
Ja, bitte. Dr. Doan am Apparat.
Guten Morgen, Herr Doan. Ich bin Frau Müller.
Ja, bitte.
Herr Meier, die Kaliumwerte liegen auf 2,6 Millimol pro Liter.
Können Sie bitte diese Werte Ihrem Oberarzt weiterleiten?
Natürlich, Frau Müller. Ich mache das. Aber können Sie bitte bestabeln?
Ich bestable M, E, I, E, R. M, E, E wie Emil, I wie Ida, E wie Emil und R wie Richard.
Okay, das habe ich geklappt. Ich mache, was Sie möchten. Danke.
Sehr schön. Herr Tchenkin. Herzlich willkommen. Herr Doan, Entschuldigung. Woher kommen Sie, Herr Doan?
Frau Oberarztin, ich komme aus der Türkei.
Seit wann sind Sie in Deutschland?
Seit etwas mehr als 2,5 Jahre in Deutschland.
Ungefähr 3 Jahre sind Sie hier?
Ja, ungefähr 3 Jahre. Ich bin in Deutschland mit meiner Familie.
Ah, Sie sind mit Ihrer Familie nach Deutschland gekommen. Okay, Sie sind verheiratet.
Ja, ich wohne mit meiner Frau und meinen zwei Söhnen in Simerath, in der Eifer Region.
Wie alt sind Sie? Ich meine Ihre Sohne.
Sie sind 10 und 13 Jahre alt.
Sie haben ungefähr zwei Teenager.
Ja, zwei Sohne zusammen, immer Streit.
Ich wünsche Ihnen sehr große Geduld.
Ja, aber Gott sei Dank habe ich Sie.
Super. Okay. Wann haben Sie Ihr Medizinstudium absolviert?
Frau Oberarztin, ich habe 2009 an der Universität Istanbul-Cerrapaşa mein Medizinstudium abgeschlossen.
Wirklich?
Wie bitte?
Ja, ja. 2000.
Ich habe 2012 an der Cerrapaşa Medizinstudium absolviert.
2012, ja.
Ah.
3 Jahre nach dem Entwurf.
Ja, okay.
Früher habe ich nicht gewusst. Deswegen war ich überrascht.
Okay. Was haben Sie heute für uns?
Frau Oberarztin, heute habe ich einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Aber bevor ich meinen Patienten vorstellen möchte ich Ihnen etwas wichtiges mitteilen.
Ich habe einen Anruf aus dem Labor bekommen.
Ich soll Ihnen sagen, Herr Meier, oder Frau Meier, Entschuldigung.
Frau Meier hat einen Kaliumspiegel von 2,6 Millimitern pro Liter.
Dieser Wert ist stark erniedrigt und entspricht Hypokalämie.
Okay. Was ist der normale Wert von Kalium?
Der normale Wert des Kaliums liegt zwischen 3,6 und 5,2 Millimitern pro Liter.
Okay. Was ist der wichtigste Urteil für Hypokalämie?
Die wichtigsten Urteile sind die Urethike, Erdbeeren, Durchfall oder Inzulintevakuum.
Okay. Welche Symptome erwarten Sie bei Hypokalämie?
Typische Symptome sind Muskelschwäche, Herzrhythmusstörungen oder Muskelkrämpfe.
Welche Herzrhythmusstörungen erwarten Sie bei Hypokalämie?
Ich erwarte Pama.
Wie können Sie das behandeln?
Ja, wir können das behandeln.
Ich meine Pama. Nicht Hypokalämie.
Pama, mit Kardioversin und Medikamenten.
Ich meine keine Medikamenten.
Kardioversin, ja.
Die Prüferinnen und Prüfer möchten Kardioversin hören.
Okay. Zuerst natürlich Gerät oder Kardioversin.
Defibrillation oder?
Defibrillation.
Wenn es Filman gibt, muss man Defibrillation behandeln.
Oder?
Okay. Was haben Sie noch?
Meine ersten Patienten oder meine zwei Patienten?
Erste Patienten.
Wenn Sie die Patienten von Ihnen untersuchen würden.
Ja, das habe ich verstanden.
Es geht um Andreas Scholten.
Er ist 33 Jahre alt.
Geboren am 8.9.1989.
Er ist 1,75 Meter groß.
Er wiegt 2,7 Kilo.
Er kam heute zu uns wegen seit 4 Tagen bestehender linkseitiger Kopfschmerzen im Hinterkopf.
Laut der Aussage des Patienten sind die Schmerzen langsam aufgetreten.
Im Laufe der Zeit wurde es schlimmer.
Er berichtet, dass die Schmerzen in den linken Arm, in den Hals und in die linke Schulter ausstrahlen.
Nach Angaben des Patienten sind die Schmerzen zehend, drückend und berennend.
Und auch bewegungsabhängig.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 8 von 10.
Außerdem hatte er ein Liche Beschwerden vor einem Monat.
Seit einem Monat hat er diese Beschwerden.
Früher war es leichter als jetzt.
Ibuprofen hat dabei gut geholfen.
Aber jetzt reicht Ibuprofen nicht aus.
Deswegen war es schwer, die Schmerzen zu bewegen.
Die Schmerzen sind in den linken Arm.
Außer Insomnias ist die Vegetative Anamnese unaufwendig.
Entschuldigung, Sie können es sagen.
Seit zwei Tagen begleitet er über Übelkeit und Parastese.
Vegetative Anamnese ergab sich aufgrund der Beschwerden Insomnias und Inapetens.
Insomnias, Inapetens, Gewichtveränderung und Schwitzen können Sie in Vegetative Anamnese nennen.
Okay, Inapetens und Insomnias.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Wenn der Patient über schmerzbedingte Schlafstörungen hat, nennen wir das Insomni oder Insomni?
Das ist eine Durchschlafstörung.
Wie können wir das nennen?
Insomni bedeutet, dass man Anfang des Schlafes Probleme hat.
Insomni umfasst Insomni und Parasomni.
Parasomni oder Durchschlafstörungen bedeutet, dass man während des Schlafs oder Schlafprozess Probleme hat.
Man kann einfach einschlafen, aber man muss immer aufwachen.
Das kann Niktur sein, das kann Schwitzen sein oder andere Probleme.
Deswegen bevorsuche ich immer meistens das Insomni zu nennen.
Aber normalerweise fehlt das nicht immer Insomni.
Aber die Insomni ist sicherlich, ich denke, sicherlich als anders.
Deswegen habe ich immer die Insomni genannt.
Vielen Dank.
An Vorerkrankungen leidet er, ich habe vielleicht falsch verstanden, 40 oder 14, aber ich habe als 40 notiert.
Deswegen sage ich 40.
Wie alt ist er?
Ich habe als 14. Lebensjahr notiert.
14. Lebensjahr.
Entschuldigung, 40. Lebensjahr.
Nein, ich frage, wie alt ist er jetzt?
Ich habe nicht verstanden, natürlich 14.
Ich habe auch immer gemischt 14, 40 oder 17, 70.
Du hast es bemerkt, wieder mische ich das.
Das ist leider vielmals zu erleben.
Aber du kannst einfach kontrollieren, wie alt er ist.
Dann kannst du einfach, ja ich habe falsch verstanden, ist das nicht möglich, natürlich 14.
Vielen Dank.
Seit 14. Lebensjahr leidet er Tinnitus.
Er leidet auch seit Langem unter leichter Kopfschmerzen.
An Operationen sind eine Osteosynthese und eine Metallfixation ausreichend.
Osteosynthese bedeutet das?
Ja.
Genau. An Operationen ist eine Osteosynthese bekannt.
Der Patient nimmt bei Bedarf überprofen 400 mg gegen Kopfschmerzen ein.
In der Kindheit hatte er eine Full Allergie.
Diese Allergie wurde durch eigene Bluttherapie behandelt.
Bei der Noxenanamnese erwähnte er täglich 3 bis 4 Zigaretten seit 5 Jahren.
Und 2 bis 3 Gläser Wein pro Woche oder am Wochenende.
Die Familienanamnese ergab einen Myokardinfarkt bei dem Vater.
Und eine arterielle Hypertonie und eine Herzkrankheit bei der Mutter.
Soziell anamnestisch ist er ...
Soll ich nachfragen über ihre Familienstand oder ist es genug? Ich bin nicht verheiratet.
Habe ich gut gemacht oder sollte ich anders machen?
Sie brauchen nicht wieder zu fragen, ob sie leidig oder geschieden sind.
Sie haben einfach gefragt, ob sie verheiratet sind. Ich bin nicht verheiratet. Ich habe einen Freund.
Das ist genug.
Soziell anamnestisch lebt er mit seiner Freundin und hat keine Kinder.
Er ist Angestellter beim Einwohnermeldung.
Sie arbeiten viel am Computer. Er ist auch Linkender.
Warum ist es genug?
Es ist wichtig, dass sie nicht verheiratet sind.
Wenn man sich die Stressfaktoren der Lebenszeit betrachtet,
kann man sich die Beziehung der Familie und der Familie positiv anbieten.
Manchmal wird sie verheiratet, aber man hat viele Probleme mit der Familie.
Du hast gefragt, ob du verheiratet bist. Ich bin nicht verheiratet.
Du hast gesagt, dass du verheiratet bist. Du hast die aktuellen Informationen schon erreicht.
Du hast die Zeit. Du hast keine Sorge, wenn du sie fragen kannst.
Du hast nicht verheiratet, aber ich bin nicht verheiratet.
Du kannst sie normalerweise fragen.
Sie sind leidig oder geschieden.
lieber nicht zu fragen, weil Zeitdruck ist, was für mich ist.
Okay.
Okay. Was ist die Diagnose?
Soll ich in der Prüfung auf den Oberarzt oder Oberärztin warten,
mögliche Fragen oder auf die mögliche Frage von Oberarztin oder Oberarzt warten
oder soll ich weitermachen nach dem Angabenmeinig?
Ja, ich bin mir nicht sicher, welche Vorstellungen sie machen können.
Zum Beispiel meine Prüfer oder meine Prüferin hat mir erlebt,
dass wir vegetarisch sind.
Dann haben sie selbst gefragt, welche Diagnose sie haben.
Aber manche Prüfer oder Prüferin haben sie bis Ende der Vorstellung erlebt.
Dann können sie weiterfahren, meine Verdacht Diagnose und so weiter.
Aber ich glaube, meistens fragen sie selbst, welche Verdacht Diagnose sie haben.
Oder was denken sie, welche Diagnose der Patient hat.
Okay. Ich kann eine kurze Pause dazwischen machen, vielleicht.
Dann können wir die Prüferin fragen.
Nach den anamnestischen Angaben habe ich den Verdacht auf
ein funktionelles Halswirbelsäule-Syndrom.
Dafür sprechen Kopfschmerzen, Nackenschmerzen, Parasthesien im Lickenarm
und intensiv am Computer oder vor dem Bildschirm arbeiten.
Differenzial diagnostisch kommen andere Ursachen des HWS-Syndroms in Betracht,
wie degeneratives HWS-Syndrom und auch Bandscheibelvorfall HWS-Syndrom.
Um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich zunächst eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Ich werde die vitalen Parameter überwachen und Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Im Labor würde ich ein kleines Blutbild, ein Entzündungsparameter, Elektrolyte, Nieren und Leber...
Was bedeutet kleines Blutbild?
Ohne die ausführlichen Parameter der Blutzellen.
Es gibt nur Lekositen, aber ob es Neurofil, Osenofil oder Basophil sind,
sind sie nicht dort geschrieben.
Nennen wir es kleines Blutbild.
Ja.
Und welche Leberwerte?
Ich habe gesagt, ja, das ist genug.
Um die möglichen Herzursachen auszuschließen, werde ich eine EKG schreiben lassen.
Darüber hinaus werde ich eine Zervikale Röntgenaufnahme in zwei Ebenen,
anterio, postero anterior und lateral, und gegebenenfalls Zervikale MLT veranlassen.
Ich werde natürlich ein orthopädisches Konzil anfordern.
Sollte sich die Verdacht Diagnose bestätigen, würde ich ihn oder den Patienten ambulant behandeln.
Als initiale Therapie würde ich Analgetika, Muskelrelexanten und Verordnungen verordnen.
Das ist als Symptomat genug, denke ich.
Und als kausale Therapie empfehle ich natürlich Physiotherapie oder Krankengymnastik.
Und die Fehlhaltungen zu korrigieren.
Vielen Dank. Sie haben sehr gut gemacht.
Beide an der Sowohl-Anamnese als auch an der Vorstellung.
Ich habe nur ein paar Empfehlungen.
In der gleichen Stelle, als ich den Patienten die Verkennung nenne,
sagt man Funktionelle Halswirbel-Zöle-Syndrom.
Ich habe das nicht gesagt.
Ich habe gesagt, Muskelverspannung im Irren nach dem Bereich.
Muskelverspannung im Irren nach dem Bereich.
Funktionelle Halswirbel-Zöle-Syndrom.
Was bedeutet Syndrom?
Das heißt, dass es für Patienten eine Angst vor sich gibt.
Muskelverspannung im Irren nach dem Bereich.
Als ihr Anamnese macht, fragt ihr, ob ihr den Beruf, den Link-Händler, den Rex-Händler,
den Habt-Bechwerde-Kurs bezeichnen könnt.
Das ist das, was wir im Kurs immer lernen.
Das ist auch immer das, was mir an die Art und Weise kommt.
Aber da muss man immer in einer Struktur sein.
Das ist eine Frage, die man im sozialen Anamnese fragen muss.
Es gibt Gespräche, die man nicht vorher fragen muss.
Wenn der Patient, wenn er den Beruf bezeichnen kann,
oder wenn er sagt, dass er viel auf dem Computer arbeitet,
dann kann man das als Vassinsi von Beruf bezeichnen.
Dann kann man das dort besprechen.
Wenn er das nicht spezifisch sagt,
dann kann man das im sozialen Anamnese fragen.
Das ist das, was ich machen wollte.
Da bin ich manchmal da.
Normalerweise habe ich die Struktur nicht bezeichnen können.
Ich vergesse immer, wenn ich was verabschiede.
Deswegen wollte ich mich da fragen.
Ich habe gesagt, wenn es wieder etwas mit Schreie oder Schmerzen gibt,
dann gehe ich zurück.
Da habe ich mich aber gefragt.
Ich habe die Patienten gefragt, ob sie in der Arbeit sind.
Ich habe gesagt, wenn es wieder mit Schreie oder mit Schmerzen geht,
dann wäre es ein Problem, wenn ich nach oben gehe.
Nein, das ist nicht ein Problem.
Das ist mir schon ganz logisch.
Aber ich habe mich dann mit den Lösungen in der Arbeit
so bezeichnet, dass ich das so mache.
Ich habe das auch so gemacht,
wenn die Patienten, wenn sie die Arbeit bezeichnen,
dann fragen sie, ob sie in der Arbeit arbeiten.
Ich habe mich da direkt gefragt.
Wenn es wieder mit Schreie oder Schmerzen geht,
dann kann ich mich da bezeichnen.
Wenn sie in der Arbeit arbeiten,
machen sie regelmäßig Pause,
dann haben sie die Hande, die Hande links oder rechts.
Wenn ich etwas sagen würde,
was die Patienten bezeichnen,
dann würde ich sie fragen.
Aber wenn sie nicht sagen,
dann würde ich sie bezeichnen.
Was ist das für ein Problem?
Ich bin in der Arbeit und ich bin in der Arbeit.
So, danke für die Aufmerksamkeit.
Ich habe seit 4 Jahren in der Medizin gearbeitet.
Im Jahr 2017 musste ich meine Stelle an der Universität leider verlassen.
Bis 2021 habe ich als Allgemeinarzt und in der Notaufnahme gearbeitet.
Aufgrund politischer Schwierigkeiten
war es für mich später nicht mehr möglich,
meinen Beruf in der Türkei frei auszuüben.
Deshalb habe ich mich entschieden, nach Deutschland zu kommen.
Ich bin überzeugt, dass ich meinen Beruf hier gut ausüben kann.
Mein Ziel in Deutschland ist es,
meine bisherigen Kenden zu ergänzen
und die notwendigen F Bildungen zu absolvieren
und dann als Hausarzt zu arbeiten.
Es gibt politische Bereiche,
wie das Beleidigungsverhalten,
die wir vorhin in den Postel haben.
Haben Sie das gehört?
Ich finde es sehr schön.
Aber ich finde es gefährlich,
die Kanzlerin die Dinge nicht in der Arbeit auszulegen.
Sie können sie in die Arbeit entgegennehmen.
Du kannst sie nicht in der Arbeit auszulegen,
aber es gibt viele andere Gründe,
warum man sie nicht in der Arbeit auszulegen.
Man braucht auch ein paar Bücher,
die man in der Arbeit nicht in der Arbeit auszulegen.
Ich habe mir vorhin gesagt,
dass ich als Politiker in der Türkei
in die politischen Bereiche komme.
Ich bin in der Türkei und in Zika und in Schwere.
Ich bin hier, weil ich politische Bereiche habe.
Ich finde die Lebensbedingungen in der Türkei
nicht sicher und schlecht.
Ich kann meine Arbeit nicht machen.
Wir sind nur darauf konzentriert.
Sie haben das Recht,
weil sie uns nicht in die Arbeit auszulegen.
Aber es gibt viele andere Gründe,
warum wir nicht in die Arbeit auszulegen.
Ich denke, sie können sich nicht in die Arbeit auszulegen.
Vielleicht denken sie auch direkt so.
Sie sind richtig.
Ich denke nur so.
Die Lebensbedingungen in der Türkei
sind nicht sicher für mich.
Ich finde es nicht sicher.
Ich finde es schlecht.
Sie sind richtig.
Ich habe es kurz gesagt.
Es gibt Menschen, die das Richtigste sagen.
Vielleicht können sie die Niveau der Erklärung
besser zeigen.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher.
Wenn du in die Arbeit auszulegen,
kannst du es nicht so einfach machen.
Ich kann meine Arbeit nicht machen.
Ich kann sie nicht so genauer machen.
Sie haben sich nicht beitragen können.
Ein Freund hat uns etwas verantwortlich gemacht.
Er arbeitet hier.
Er ist in der ersten Saison in der Dürsel 4.
Er ist in die Arbeit gekommen,
aber er konnte nicht in die Arbeit auszulegen.
Er hat keine politischen Probleme,
aber sein Vater hatte Probleme.
Er hat die Gründe der Politik verantwortlich.
Sie können sich die Zeit erzielen.
Sie können sich das schon machen.
Das ist meine einzige Frau.
Ich finde, es ist alles schön.
Vielen Dank.
Inpek, bitte.
Ich kann es nicht.
10 Sekunden sind vorbei.
Okay.
Ja.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Inpek.
Ich bin hier.
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Inpek.
Heute habe ich einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Darf ich vorstellen?
Ja, bitte schön.
Bevor würde ich Ihnen etwas Wichtiges mitteilen.
Ich habe einen Anruf aus dem Labor bekommen.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Herr Müller, Entschuldigung, Herr Mayer.
Herr Mayer?
Herr.
Okay, ich habe falsch verstanden.
Ich habe Frau Mayer verstanden.
Herr Mayer hat einen Kalium-Spiegel
von 2,6 Millimol pro Liter.
Ja, jetzt darf ich meinen Patienten vorstellen.
Ja, natürlich, bitte schön.
Okay.
Es geht um Andreas Scholten.
Er ist 33 Jahre alt, geboren am 08.09.1989.
Er ist 1,75 Meter groß
und wiegt 2,7 Kilogramm.
Er kann seit 4 Tagen
linksseitige Schmerzen im Nacken und Hinterkopf.
Die Schmerzencharakter sind wie siehende,
brennende und...
Die Schmerzcharakter ist?
Die Schmerzcharakter ist wie siehend, brennend und drückend
sowie progredient.
Laut Aussage des Patienten
sind die Schmerzen langsam aufgetreten
und strahlen diese Schmerzen
in die linke Schulter,
in den linken Arm
und in den Hals.
Nach Angaben des Patienten
liegt die Schmerzintensität bei 8 von 10 auf NRS.
Deswegen habe ich den Aufnahmegespräch untergebracht
und habe eine Energetik verabschieden.
Welche Energetik?
Novalgen.
Welche Wirkstoffe enthält Novalgen?
Metronidazol.
Metronidazol?
Metamizol.
Außerdem hat er diese Schmerzen
seit einem Monat.
Aber damals waren die Schmerzen leichter
und manchmal hat eine Wärmekiste geholfen.
Aber seit vier Tagen
hat diese Medikamente und Wärmekiste nicht geholfen.
Hilf nicht.
Begleitend klagt er Schmerzbedingte Übelkeit
und Parastese im linken Arm.
Vegetativ anämnistisch bis auf Katzschweiß,
Schmerzbedingte Insomnie und Inapetens
ist unaufällig.
Er hat vor 14 Jahren eine Erkrankung.
Er hat die Schmerzen im ganzen Kopf
und ein bis zwei Ataken pro Monat.
Er hat eine Osteosynthese wegen eines linken Unterarmfraktos
und wegen eines Unterschenkelfraktos.
Unterschenkel oder Unterarm?
Unterarm.
Und Unterschenkel?
Nur Unterarm.
Zuerst hast du Unterarm gesagt,
dann Unterchenkel.
Deswegen habe ich gefragt.
Vielleicht habe ich falsch notiert.
Okay, danke für die Information.
In der Kindheit hatte er Polynosis,
die mit einer eigenen Bluttherapie behandelt wurde.
Bei der Noxon-Anamnese erwähnte er täglich zwei bis drei
Zigaretten seit fünf Jahren und zwei, drei Gläser Wein
am Wochenende. Drogenkonsum würde verneint.
Die Familienanamnese,
sein Vater ist an Emae verstorben.
Er war 55 Jahre alt.
Und so wie seine Mutter leidet an arteriöle Hypertonie,
ist er ledig mit seinen Freunden zusammenleben
und hat keine Kinder.
Er ist anstellt in einem Wohnmeldamt,
arbeitet täglich acht Stunden am Computer,
vielleicht manchmal ohne Pause.
Nach diesem anamnistischen Angaben
passen seine Beschwerden
mit dem Funktionellen Halswirbelsäule-Syndrom.
Dafür schiebreichen Kopfschmerzen,
linkseitige Parasthesie,
Belastungsarbeit und Linkhänder.
Er ist Linkhänder.
Als Differenziazdiagnose kommen
Akutt-Coronär-Syndrom und
cervicaler Discusprolapsus in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen,
zuerst würde ich körperliche Untersuchungen
durchführen, besonders neurologische Untersuchungen,
sensibler,
sensibler, motorische Untersuchungen,
vital Parameter aufwachen,
überwachen, Entschuldigung,
etwas Blut abnehmen, Blutbild,
Blutzucker natürlich, und Vitamin D,
Vitamin B12, Entzündungsparameter,
dann natürlich Troponin T,
und CKMB auch kann sein.
Dann Nierenlaborwert, Herzmuskelnentzüm,
Entschuldigung, ja, dann würde ich gerne
operative Untersuchungen durchführen,
um die Ultraschall-MRT zu verhindern.
Welche Ultraschall würden Sie durchführen?
In welchem Körper?
Ich bin nicht sicher jetzt. Vielleicht
mit dem Nacken gibt es Schwellung,
Lymphodenopathie, das kann
drücken die Nerven oder so. Ich denke das, aber vielleicht
das ist falsch.
Ich kann nur vielleicht Lymphopathie suchen,
nicht anders. Aber Ihre operative Diagnostikmethode
kann zusammenhängen mit Ferdatdiagnose oder
Differentialdiagnose. Ja, richtig.
Mit der Differentialdiagnose nennen Sie
Akutkorener-Syndrom. Ja, und EKG natürlich.
Und vielleicht werden Sie
Eco-Kardio, nicht Eco nennen.
Meine Differentialdiagnose ist Akutkorener-Syndrom,
deswegen würde ich eine Eco-Kardio veranlassen.
Können Sie sagen. Okay.
Und Röntgenaufnahme in zwei Ebenen,
Posterior, Anterior und Lateral-Lateral-MRT.
Ich werde ein orthopäisches
Konzil anfordern. Auch gegebenenfalls nach dem
Labor vielleicht kardiologisches Konzil.
Sollte sich die Ferdatdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich in
Ambulantentherapie behandeln und
die Patienten-Schulung
besonders Ergotherapie, Gymnastik oder
Physiotherapie
und natürlich
die energetische und muskul-relaxante
Verordnung. Ja. Okay. Das war alles.
Vielen Dank.
Ultraschall, da will ich etwas sagen.
Hier gibt es viele andere Dinge, die man
ansehen kann. Tendocinovit,
Tia, Parastese,
Oa,
Oageroche,
Kopschmerzen,
Tia. In diesen Situationen kann man auch Ultraschall
und Karotest, Duplersonographie
und
ist das erste Mal, dass du diese Symptome
seit einem Monat,
wo hast du die Schreite, sei es dann schon
so, wie sie deswegen beim Hausarzt
gibt. Und dann ist es die
andere, dass du die Schmerzen
genaue Beschreibung, die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala
gibt es etwas, dass Schmerzen verstärkt, zum Beispiel
Warmekissen, ein Schmerzmittel, ein Genomen, ein Schmerzmittel, ein Name,
so kann man das beobachten.
Jetzt, da es Schmerzen gibt, weil man
ein Kind hat,
ich habe Schmerzen-Sorgen
nach dem Schluss gesagt,
wenn ein Kind Schmerzen hat,
ist das sehr wichtig,
dann ist es wichtig,
die Schmerzen, die Schmerzen,
diese Tier zu怎en,
um diese Schmerzen aufzunehmen.
Antworten Sie mich, dass Sie
Schmerzen, Schmerzen und Schmerzen haben.
Hier ist eine Parastese, Parasite
oder Hypostese,
ich habe diese Antworten gefragt.
Dann gibt es auch Zinsirlicht-Empfindlich, Lärm-Empfindlich, die die Migräne ausfüllen.
Das sieht sehr viel aus, aber wenn man die beiden Fragen zusammenführt, ist es nicht viel.
Ich habe die Frage gestellt, was die wichtigsten Fragen sind, die ich in der Zeit für die Änderung der Migräne ausfüllen kann.
Z-Empfindlich, Hörstörung, Sprachstörung, die Apoplexie,
Lehmann-Erscheinung, Parastese, Pestese, die die T-Empfindlich-Empfindlich, Lärm-Empfindlich, die Migräne ausfüllen.
Arbeiten Sie täglich mit dem Computer?
Können Sie regelmäßig Pause machen bei der Arbeit oder während der Arbeit?
Welche Hand benutzen Sie meistens? Oder sind Sie linkshändler oder rechtshändler?
Ich habe hier die Frage gestellt.
Aber hier ist die Arbeit, die mich nicht sagen kann.
Ich habe die Fragen in der Zeit für die Berufung, die ich in der Zeit für die Sozialanamnesik beantworten.
Die Fragen sind so. Ich frage die Schmerzen.
Weil ich Kopfschmerzen habe, habe ich die Fragen in der Neurologik.
Schmerzen, Engagefühl, Herzrazen,
Sie können sich dort auch fragen.
Das sieht sehr schön aus.
Aber wenn Sie sich dort fragen, ist das kein Problem.
Sie können sich in der Vegetative-Anamnesik-Küste fragen.
Schmerzen, Engagefühl, Herzrazen, Lufnod,
um den Akut-Karrener-Syndrom auszuweichen.
Dann gibt es die Gastrointestinal Systemfragen.
Übüllkait, Erbrechen, Stürgang-Probleme, Wasalasen-Probleme.
Dann gibt es auch keine anderen, die sich an die Berufung beantworten.
Das habe ich auch schon gesagt.
Meine Fragen sind so.
In der Sozialanamnesik-Küste,
ich würde immer die Stress-Fragen stellen.
Ich habe es nicht so oft gesagt, aber
die Stress-Fragen sind ein Risiko für alle Krankheiten.
Ich halte die Frage an.
Jetzt gibt es Bahadir.
Er wird jetzt in den Saison-Küste.
Wir haben einen prayen.
Felsa ist dabei.
Wir können ihn in der Saison-Küste einmelden.
Wir können ihn nicht schanzen.
Er hat eine Alarm-Probe.
Osman, Bahadir.
Ich werde ihn nicht schanzen.
Ich werde auch in der Saison-Küste einen prayen.
Danke.
Und um in die Kassel zu gehen, soll ich etwas machen.
Habt ihr einen Tipps von den Jungs bekommen?
Das ist sehr wichtig. Sie zeigen die Ausgabe.
Ich werde eine Übungsweise gegen den Ort machen.
Sie sagen, es sei unvergesslich, also werde ich es nicht verraten.
Okay, okay.
Das ist die Hauptentwicklung der Arztkamera.
Das ist der Beratungsplatz.
Da hinten ist eine Frau.
Sie kommt, und dort ist das FSP.
Das ist ein ganz ganzes Ort.
Das ist der erste Desk, an dem die Beratungsleiter kommen.
Wir fragen, ob wir in den FSP gehen.
Du sagst, dass du zuerst da bist, und dann wirst du hier warten.
Dann gehst du in die Kassel, und dann gehst du in die Kassel.
Okay, dann geht's los.
Ich hoffe, dass es dir hilft.
Das ist der Baha Duru.
Ist es? Dann gehen wir los.
Ich hoffe, dass es dir hilft.
Die Kassel wird in die Kassel gebrannt.
Okay, dann gehen wir los.
Dusser, du bist gut. Wir brauchen die Oberarzt.
Ich hoffe, dass es dir hilft.
Ich habe keine Beze, aber ...
Danke.
Ich hoffe, dass es dir hilft.
Das war die Frage.
Ich glaube, ich habe sie schon beendet.
Die Fragen waren die Reaktionen.
Ja, die Reaktionen waren die Reaktionen.
Ich habe nichts zu tun. Ich bin verabschiedet.
Du hast gesagt, dass du immer Stresses fragst.
Ja, ich frage immer Stresses.
Du hast gesagt, dass du nicht so viel gesagt hast.
Jetzt kommen wir zu den Details.
Ich will etwas extra sagen.
Stress ist sehr wichtig.
Es ist für alle Krankheiten sehr wichtig.
Wenn Sie auf ein Krankheitsdienst
einen Rizikofaktor fragen,
können Sie alle Stresses sagen.
Deswegen ist es wichtig,
dass die Krankheiten Stressen fragen.
Stress bei der Arbeit oder im Privatleben.
Ich fand das immer wichtig.
Ich habe das immer bei der sozialen Anamnesie gefragt.
Viele von ihnen
verabschieden sich von Stress.
Das tut mir leid.
Das ist sehr ...
...
Das ist sehr belastend.
Ich habe vorhin etwas gesagt.
Wenn er es nicht sagt,
dann frage ich ihn.
Reaktionen sind auch
die Reaktionen hier.
Der Herr Çetin hat alle Reaktionen
Ich habe auch solche Gedanken gemacht.
Dann gibt es auch eine Herzkrise.
Mein Vater hatte auch solche Fragen.
Ich habe Angst, weil ich eine Herzkrise habe.
Aber ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass sie eine Herzkrise haben.
Denn ihre Beschwerden passen nicht zu einer Herzkrise.
Aber wir werden eine notwendige Untersuchung durchführen, um das abzuklaren.
Mein Vater hatte eine Herzkrise.
Er sagte, dass ich eine Herzkrise habe.
Aber es gibt viele weitere Beschwerden.
Was anderes?
Wie kannst du mit Stress anfangen?
Hast du eine Frage?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Du kannst es nicht so schnell fragen.
Du musst es in 18 Minuten machen.
Du kannst es nicht so schnell sagen.
Aber es ist keine richtige Frage.
Ich habe es nicht gefragt.
Ich kann es nicht mehr beantworten.
Es gibt eine Geschichte von Vollnarkose.
Okay.
Dann geht es um Vollnarkose.
Ich wollte es so sagen.
Es tut mir leid, dass Sie eine solche Situation erleben müssen.
Ich glaube, dass der Arzt zuerst eine örtliche Betäubung versuchte.
Aber leider konnten Sie es nicht schaffen.
Dann haben Sie eine Vollnarkose.
Ich bin sehr verletzt, dass Sie das erleben.
Ich glaube, dass die Arztinnen zuerst eine örtliche Betäubung versuchten.
Aber leider konnten sie es nicht.
Dann haben sie eine Vollnarkose.
Ich bin sehr verletzt, dass Sie eine solche Situation erleben müssen.
Ich glaube, dass der Arzt zuerst eine örtliche Betäubung versuchte.
Damit Sie weniger Nebenwirkungen haben konnten.
Aber leider konnten Sie es nicht schaffen.
Ich glaube, dass der Arzt zuerst eine örtliche Betäubung versuchte.
Dann haben Sie eine Vollnarkose.
Ich glaube, dass die Arztinnen zuerst eine örtliche Betäubung versuchten.